dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly Shana if a here we
have had quite a few episodes on
simulating the motion of fluids and
creating beautiful footages from the
results in this work the author's
created a simulator that shows us not
only the motion of a piece of fluid but
the physics of bubbles within as well
this sounds great but there are two huge
problems one there are a lot of them and
two they can undergo all kinds of
deformations and topology changes to
conjure up video footage that is
realistic and relates to the real world
several bubble related effects such as
entrainment splitting merging advection
and collapsing all have to be simulated
faithfully however there is a large body
of research out there to simulate
bubbles and here we are not only
interested in the footage of this piece
of fluid but also what kind of sounds it
will emit when we interact with it the
result is something like this
you
the vibrations of a bubble is simulated
by borrowing the equations that govern
the movement of Springs in physics
however this by itself would only be a
forlorn attempt at creating a faithful
sound simulation as there are other
important factors to take into
consideration for instance the position
of the bubble matters a great deal this
example shows that the pitch of the
sound is expected to be lower near solid
walls as you can see it marked with dark
blue on the Left right side and below
and have a higher pitch near the surface
which is marked with red you can also
see that there are significant
differences in the frequencies depending
on the position the highest frequency
being twice as high as the lowest so
this is definitely an important part of
the simulation furthermore taking into
consideration the shape of the bubbles
is also of utmost importance
as the shape of the bubble goes from an
ellipsoid to something close to a sphere
the immediate sound frequency can drop
by as much as 30% beyond these effects
there were still blind spots even in
state-of-the-art simulations with
previous techniques a chirp like sound
was missing which is now possible to
simulate with a novel frequency
extension model additional extensions
include a technique that models the
phenomenon of the bubbles popping at the
surface the paper discusses what cases
are likely to emphasize which of these
extensions effects putting it all
together it sounds magnificent check it
out
but still however create these sounds
are without proper validation these are
still just numbers on a paper and of
course as always the best way of testing
these kinds of works if we let reality
be our judge and compare the results to
real-world footage so I think you can
guess what the next test is going to be
about our frequency model matches
experiments well such as this entrained
bubble and this bubble released from an
underwater tube
the authors also put up a clinic on
physics and math and the entirety of the
paper is absolutely beautifully written
I definitely recommend having a look as
always the link is available in the
description box also you'll find one
more link to a playlist with all of our
previous episodes on fluid simulations
lots of goodies there as always we'd
love to read your feedback on this
episode let us know whether you have
found it understandable I hope you did
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time